while nevada is facing a continued surge
of covet cases there is hope
on the horizon good evening i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez earlier tonight
the governor says a limited
number of vaccines will soon be in
nevada this month
but still a lot needs to happen before
everyone can get one
sasha loftus is in our newsroom tonight
with more on the governor's update
sasha denise and brian great news on the
vaccine front governor sysolak says he
hopes to have the first
round of vaccination doses available in
the next few weeks
by the middle of december here in nevada
the state will give frontline health
care workers the first possible doses
with vaccines set to be available to the
general public by the spring or
summer of 2021. now governor sisalek and
his team mentioned the two vaccines
we've been hearing about
moderna and pfizer both of which have an
efficacy rate of around 95 percent
again frontline and healthcare workers
will receive their initial doses
first and then the state will work with
pharmaceutical companies to administer
the first dose to our most vulnerable
populations
that's about three thousand people or so
governor sislek also spoke on the hope
this vaccine brings to end a dark period
here in nevada and across the country
i have hope now a vaccine is coming
within weeks
we will begin distributing and giving
people needle sticks
i mean that's a positive thing this has
been done in record time
and it's our hope that we can get as
much of this as we can out in the
general public
we'll build more and more immunity and
we can start to get back to our regular
life
the governor sisalek also wanted to
emphasize that the vaccine
will be administered in two doses with
the first available again this month
the time in between doses would either
be 21 or 28 days depending on
whether it's pfizer or moderna which is
administered the governor also mentioned
our current numbers here in nevada that
they're concerning to both him
and to our health care workers he is
encouraging urging everyone rather to
take all necessary precautions
so he does not have to reinstate any
closures here in nevada
or of course here in las vegas denise